ganz grundsätzlich ist es sehr sehr
schwierig eine Partei zu verbieten
unabhängig von der AFD man muss
nachweisen dass eine Partei als
Gesamtheit also wirklich auch die
Führungsetage nicht nur einzelne
Personen nicht nur einzelne Flügel
sondern die Partei als Gesamtheit aktiv
die freiheitliche demokratische
Grundordnung bekämpft so und dann ist
die nächste Frage hunderttausende
unterschreiben gerade eine Petition die
die wirkrechte von Björn höcke
Grundrechte von ihm einschränken sollen
nach Artikel 18 Grundgesetz wäre das
juristisch
einfacher ja das ist juristisch
einfacher aber auch da muss man sagen es
gab bis langang viermal den Versuch
diesen Weg zu gehen es ist viermal
gescheitert das heißt nicht dass es noch
mal scheitern würd es ist deutlich
einfacher als ein Parteiverbotsverfahren
und es hätte ja auch zur Folge dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht anordnen könnte
dass ein Björn höcke sollte das
Verfahren erfolgreich sein nicht zur
Wahl antreten darf oder aber sogar
gewählt wie kein öffentliches Amt
begkleiten darf